>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Beacher Wiggins:
Good morning, everyone.
I'm Beacher Wiggins,
Director for Acquisitions
and Bibliographic Access
here at the Library,
and it's again a pleasure
to start off, and actually,
this is our first
session for the year
of LC's Digital Future and You!
that is coordinated by Angela
Kinney and Judith Cannan,
two of the chiefs in ABA,
who have been doing this
for a little while now.
And we try to find interesting
topics and presenters to come
and help keep you informed in
some of the latest that's going
on related to automation
applications
and automated techniques.
This morning, I am particularly
pleased because we are focusing
on BIBFRAME, the
model that the Library
of Congress has been
developing under the auspices
of Network Development and MARC
Standards Office, Sally McCallum
and her capable staff, have been
developing what we're expecting
to be the replacement
for the MARC format.
I have been working with
our presenters this morning,
Tiziana Possemato, and Michele
Casalini for a while now.
We have been involved
with Casalini as one
of our leading acquisitions
vendors,
and in the past few years with
their exploration and working
with BIBFRAME as a model
and helping us to prove
that BIBFRAME can be
expanded and is scalable.
Their involvement with
BIBFRAME has been related
to their development
of the shared virtual discovery
environment in linked data,
what they are dubbing SHARE-VDE,
and they will be talking
about that this morning.
And SHARE-VDE is a
community-driven research
and development project with a
chief goal of bringing BIBFRAME
into a practice that libraries,
librarians, and the library
and library patrons
can put to good use.
So, they'll give us some sense
of what they've been doing
with this, and the Library
of Congress has been one
of the institutions that
has been working with them
on the SHARE-VDE approach.
Tiziana is the Chief
Information Officer of Casalini,
and she's also Director
of @CULT.
She holds a degree in philosophy
from La Sapienza in Rome
and diplomas in Archival
Science and Library Sciences
from the Vatican Library Schools
and has also a master's degree
in Library Sciences from
the University of Florence.
She has led numerous
projects during her career,
both for library automation, for
analysis mapping and conversion,
and for the transformation
of LinkUp and data
into a publication format
for numerous institutions.
Michele Casalini is the
Managing Director of Casalini,
which produces authority
data and bibliographic data
in addition to supplying
books and journals
for the customer
base of Casalini.
Following studies in Modern
languages and literature
at the University of Florence
and a period of working
in the publishing
company La Nuova Italia,
Michele specialized in
the field of Information
and Technology Management.
Michele is also a board member
of the Council on Library
and Information Resources.
So, we have very well-informed
presenters this morning,
and I look forward to
hearing what they have to say,
even though I am
familiar with some of it,
and I more especially
want you as LC staff
to hear what's been going on.
So, Tiziana and Michele,
and I'll let you decide
who goes first, and maybe
you play off each other.
>> Michele Casalini: Thank
you very much, Beacher,
and thank you all
for being here.
For Tiziana and me, it's a
great privilege to be here today
and to have the opportunity
to talk to you
about the SHARE Virtual
Discovery Environment project.
As you know, Casalini Libri
is one of the main suppliers
of European publications,
cataloging,
and technical services
to academic libraries
across the world.
We have been working with the
Library of Congress for decades,
are a member of PCC, the Program
for Cooperative Cataloging,
participating in NACO and SACO,
and our original cataloging
division has received valuable
input from the Library during
the implementation of RDA
which begun on day one,
March 31st of 2015.
After the first year of RDA,
we began to collect input
from the Library community
on the application and tools
of the emerging BIBFRAME
data model.
The input received form the
wider library community and,
in particular, the Library
of Congress, made it clear
that we would in the future be
expected to supply data not only
in MARC format but also
according to the new framework.
In response, we embarked
on a strategy
for the progressive
implementation of BIBFRAME
in close collaboration
with @CULT,
our long-standing
technological partner
with extensive experience
in technological solutions
for cultural heritage
institutions.
@CULT has also been a
technological partner
of [inaudible], automatic
publication
and a linked data
provider of library data,
an European community
funded project.
Following a series
of initial studies
and a feasibility
analysis in January 2016,
we presented the first
results and a plan for action
at the Library of Congress
BIBFRAME Update Forum
at Midwinter ALA in Boston.
Considering that this evolution
had an effect on many aspects
of the traditional Library
catalog, for example,
the format, organization,
and retrieval of data,
the objectives stand out
and interpretations will be
in continuous transformation
for quite some time.
Each organization will have
its own specific workflow.
We were very pleased in the
summer 2016 to receive approval
and support of 12 North
American institutions
for the SHARE-VDE project.
We are particularly grateful
to our contacts and colleagues
at Stanford University Libraries
for their valuable
thrust and encouragement.
We feel a great responsibility
and ever-growing enthusiasm
for this research and
development initiative,
which aims to make real steps
toward the effective use
of BIBFRAME.
Seeing not only the
practical results
but also the incredible
potential of linked data
for providing discoverability
has been extremely satisfying.
Indeed, using linked
data in libraries,
catalogs can provide a
number of advantages.
It gives visibility to and
other information and resources
that would otherwise be hidden.
It helps to connect and improve
interoperability among library
archives and museum domains.
It is a basis for new
cooperative initiatives
in the sector, and it
improves accessibility
for library patrons
and the wider public
with the ultimate benefit of
safeguarding cultural heritage.
Of course, some problems
have emerged during our work
on the project, and
we will see some
of these during the
presentation.
The work is since the beginning
based on the requirements
and expectations of
the library community,
and this will be the driving
force for the definition
of the activities and priorities
to be put into production,
the Phase III, modulizing
and parametrizing individual
components as necessary.
I hope there will
be enough time later
for questions and
for a discussion.
With that in mind, let's
now look into details
at the results of
Phase I and II.
I will cover only the first
part of the presentation.
The majority will be
handled by Tiziana Possemato,
who is the Director
of the project.
This is the index of the topics
that we will cover this morning.
I'm sorry.
You already know who we are,
and we are based in Florence
and Rome and a little bit,
I mean, the background
of our company that
I mentioned before.
What we are at the
starting point
of a design of the project.
First of all, the enrichment of
MARC records with URIs in order
to simplify and make the
BIBFRAME conversion possible
and more effective, of course.
The use of a framework to
automate the conversion
from MARC into RDF, using
BIBFRAME vocabulary,
and the creation of a BIBFRAME
layered platform prototype
starting from bibliographic
and authority records, to test
and to demonstrate
the advantages
that the BIBFRAME data model
is bringing, and this has been
in order for us at the
beginning a surprising element
because we understood that it
is necessary in order to discuss
and to share future
plans with the community,
really to touch completely the
potential advantages of the new,
that the new data
model can bring.
The main goals of Phase
1 and 2 of that Research
and Development project
has been a reconciliation
and clusterization of variant
forms of the same entity,
a key element and starting point
for several further activities;
the enrichment of MARC records
with URIs with the development
of detection procedures
for entity identification,
including relator terms;
the conversion, supply,
and management of authority
and bibliographical data
in BIBFRAME taking into account
the complexity of the long
and heterogeneous transition
time on both the library
and the data producer sides; and
the publication, as I mentioned,
of a BIBFRAME three-layered
platform prototype.
Phase 1, in particular,
has seen the contribution
of the participating
libraries with their datasets
with their record of two
imprint years, 1985 and 2015.
The reason to have these
two different imprint years,
we are to have a record
so that we are based
on the different rules, and
the RDA records in 2015 and,
of course, pre-RDA
records for 1985.
A total of approximately 2
million bibliographical records
and 3 million authority
records were processed,
converted at that time in
BIBFRAME 1 and then released
on the SHARE-VDE portal.
This phase ended one year ago.
Phase 2 of the project,
and it was seen that each
of the participant libraries
sent us their entire catalog.
So, we handled approximately
100 million bibliographical
and authority records.
A relationship database that
registers the relationships
between entities, person,
work, instances, subjects,
publishers is established
in order
to assure a more precise
identification rate
for each entity in order
to reach a higher quality
of results without
human intervention.
And of course, we have worked on
refinement of data, for example,
for co-authors or editors,
where there is a variety of ways
in which they are
identified in library records.
And Phase 2 handled the
export of data in RDF format,
filtering the library preferred
URIs, of course, in BIBFRAME 2.
And we included URI sources
from a number of projects.
We analyzed, and we made an
analysis for the creation
of the relationships between
subject terms and strings
in different languages,
and we worked
on the Provenance
Declaration, update management,
and built-in instances that
are also quite key elements
and prerequisites for
the production scene.
So, we ended now Phase 2,
and we are now discussing
with the library community
about priorities and use cases
for a modular implementation,
introduction
of the various components
for Phase 3.
That will, of course, vary
from institution to institution
because worker workflows
are different,
the habits are different,
and so there is absolutely
not one schema that works,
one working schema
that works for all.
These are, this is a list
of the participant libraries
in Phase 1 and/or
Phase 2 of the project.
So, I ask now Tiziana to move
on with a very brief overview
of theoretical context.
>> Tiziana Possemato: Thank you.
The theoretical context
will be briefly, of course,
because you know all these
environments where we are,
and we started from March
21, and we analyze the factor
of a conversion using RDA
records and, of course,
we try to have in mind also
the International Cataloging
Principles and the FRBR model.
And of course, to
arrive to a conversion
in semantic web linked
data using specifically
but not totally BIBFRAME.
So, our focus is on
BIBFRAME but, of course,
each library can choose to
add additional anthologies
to complete the BIBFRAME used as
core, as a heart of the project.
Why we focus on ADA linked
up in that and BIBFRAME
because if you think this
guideline serve format model
at all related to
exactly the same model,
that is an entity
relationship model.
So, had in mind in
any case the entities
and the relationship
between them.
So, also this type of a cultural
environment has something
in common.
And so I can try to share you,
with you the process
overview of SHARE-VDE.
In this picture is,
summarizes some
of important steps
of the project.
Starting from the left, where
we indicated the different types
and different format of data
records, not only MARC 21
but other family of
MARC or rather formats
and not specifically MARC.
The record that a
worker have handled
and using two different
processes, the main processes,
of course, is similar this
core process, but is a lot
of algorithms to identify,
similarity in heading,
for example, and to find the
similarity in the records
and so on, and the Authify.
The Authify is important because
it's a tool; it's a process
that makes use of external
sources such as the Library
of Congress's subject
heading, the NAF, ISNI Library
of Congress Authority file and
son on to reach information
and to simplify the
classification process.
So, both processes,
the similarity score
and Authify produce
an entity detection
to identify specifically
each entity that is present
in a description, the enrichment
of information with the URIs
but also with additional
attributes in different format
and the reconciliation
classification process.
That is really the
key concept we hope,
of course, of our project.
So, starting from this
output, we produce a database
of relationship because as
you know MARC records are full
of relationships, not
clearly expressed,
but each record presents full
relationships between entities.
So, we reported and we
are creating a database
of relationships, a
knowledge base of clusters
because of the clusterization
and the reconciliation
process produce a lot
of relationship between,
for example, body and form
to identify a name, a person,
and go through the Lodify
that is the commercial
tool we produce.
We release a record, the data,
in RDF to be published
autonomously by library
or to be published in
the SHARE-VDE portal.
So, some focus on
some processes.
We start usually from
authority records.
In fact, as Michele told, we
receive authority records not
from all libraries but from
libraries who manage this kind,
type of record, and we manage
authority records using the
similarity score and
Authify tool samples.
We use a clusters knowledge
base as a bridge to relate
and to save and store some
information that we need.
For example, all the variant
form of a heading of the person,
and we produce the
class and knowledge base
in RDF, link it up in data.
The second step is manage
the bibliographic records.
So, the bibliographic record
use, again, the similarity score
and the Authify tools and
enrich the Postgress database.
And finally, we produce
a MARC enriched record.
So, MARC enriched with the URIs
coming from different sources,
and the process 2, we start
from the clusters knowledge base
to convert the record
using the Lodify
and to store it in
a Triplestore.
We mention here Blazegraph
that is
in Open Source Triplestore even
if we are considering other
solutions more powerful
than Blazegraph.
But in any case the important is
the concept of the Triplestore.
And the second one, we publish
the class that knowledge base.
We produce and publish
knowledge base and a second one
of the bibliographic record that
pass through the similar process
and Lodify, the Triplestore,
and we produce each dataset
for each library related to
the class of knowledge base.
I always try to explain
after this sense,
the sense of this relation,
and we produce also the MARC
and reach the in a [inaudible]
format or other format.
So, just to give you a very
brief idea of our technology,
as you can see, the class
assembly base is the heart
of the project because we think
that is the power of the project
to have the entity,
the conciliated
and perfectly identified.
And we now are working
in a new function
to create a new cluster starting
from the already existent,
but we will explain this
at the end of presentation.
And just a brief look
to our technology,
we try to put together
different type of technology
because what the Triplestore
can do well is something but not
so well as a relational
database or not so well
as an immersive index
such as SOLR.
So, we try to put together
all this type of technologies
to use the best of each of
them and to put together.
So, I tried to explain to you
the Entity Identification,
Reconciliation, and Data
Enrichment processes.
So, of course, I will jump
this slide about the someone
of you probably never have seen,
but our first question is how
to identify an entity,
starting from a standard record
or a standard description, and
the identification question,
problem, is something
that is for all persons,
all people in the world and
for all type of information.
So, in this case,
in this picture,
you can see different
version, different picture
of the same people, Albert
Camus of the same person,
Albert Camus, and each of
these representation is a valid
representation of him.
It's not something that
is more real than another.
All the representations
are valid
that represent the same
person, Albert Camus.
So, in our process, we try
to identify Albert Camus
as a person, as a real
world object in the world,
as a real person and to
give him an identification,
a unique identification
but using
in the same type the unique
identification, okay, each,
that each project in the work
assigned to the same person,
to put together information
for the exactly
and uniquely person
that is Albert Camus.
But as I told you, the
importance of identification
in this, not only in the
cataloging tradition,
is something that is related to
all people and the inner world.
For example, this has
two pictures taken
at the City Lights
Bookstore in San Francisco
where a door is expressly
indicated with a note,
I am a Door, or Corporations
are not People.
So, something, the [inaudible]
identified perfectly the
entities of something that
is related to all the world.
So, with the online presence
of different catalogs
and authority files that are
available in the various formats
and various, following various
guidelines and in open mode.
Also the concept of
authority control
or of union catalog
evolved into the grouping
of an entity's identifying
attributes
from different sources.
And this process is best known
as reconciliation and consists
in creating a cluster,
a group of data,
that all refer to
the same entity.
And so, we start
exactly from the record
that is our tradition
in cataloging.
We start from a record to
arrive to identify each entity
that is present in a record.
And for example, just to give
you some brief ideas about this,
we can define the drive
[inaudible] from a record.
We can derive when
we have, when we can.
Of course, a work
from a MARC record is
such that they probably
shared the attributes
to identify an instance
and so on.
So, we try to identify
each entity that is defined
and record it in a record.
But as you know, for
each of these entities,
we can have a different
expression,
different description,
and different languages.
So, you're following
different rules.
So, we need to put together this
body and form, consider them
as different attributes
of the same entity.
And for these, we thought
about a shared project
to put together information
coming from different sources
and to perfectly
identify entities
and put them in relationship.
So, bring together and
make available data
from different sources in a way
that we can consider
a democratic way
so that doesn't exist, the
one form that is the best
for the world, but each
character, each person think
that is the best for himself.
And so, we try to identify
the entity in question,
and this is the base of
our SHARE-VDE project.
So, starting from traditional
record before and after RDA,
and we notice, of course, that
some important differences
in converting data
before and after RDA,
but we need to convert
all data that we have.
So, we finally try to be able
to identify, for example,
a work with its relationship.
So, a work related to subjects
that are managed and work
with the creator, with the
publications and so on.
Or we can, we find, we
define, for example, a subject,
the Thomas Mann in this case
as a subject or of something.
All books that will
speak about Thomas Mann,
all we hope we will be able to
define and to find the publisher
and know its relationship.
For example, [inaudible]
in a relation with places,
with other forms that are
related to the same publisher,
the best some of the people who
published with this publisher,
the subject and so on.
Or this is an example of
clusterization and, for example,
an example of a collaboration
and sharing.
So, this is the result
for Antonio Vivaldi
of all forms coming from the
authority, local authority file,
all forms coming from VIAF
project, all forms coming
from cross reference taken
from authority record,
or probably also the
forms that are used
in bibliographical record
and that doesn't
match with authority.
Because we can imagine that all
these forms are used by someone
to search an entity and
to define an entity.
And so, this is an example of
Work/Instances reconciliation.
This is a work of Vivaldi
Cimento dell'armonia e
dell-inventione, and
all possible instances.
So, a different title to
identify an instance related
to the same work, to the
same intellectual production
of a person or, for
example, the instance,
a different instance is
present in different libraries,
so the same instance that is
present in different libraries
and put together in one group
so that the end user can simply
define and find the information
and choose what he needs.
So, how reconciliation
and enrichment can work.
We work using usually
two different processes.
One is an automated process,
and the second one is a manual
process because, as you know,
Casalini produce records
for different libraries
so has the opportunity to work
on the records during
the production.
Of course, taking
in consideration
that automated process produce
a high level of reconciliation
and clusterization but a low
level of results validation
because are automated processes.
And contrary, manual
processes produce a low level
of reconciliation and
clustering and a high level
of results validation.
So, we think that to put
together will produce the
best result.
And this is again the
same picture than before
to identify automated
reconciliation
and enrichment process.
So, using in this case,
Antonio Vivaldi as an entity
and reaching this entity
with all the forms coming
from different projects
and so on.
And for this process, the heart
of the process is Authify.
I'll try to explain to you
briefly what is Authify,
a general description.
Authify is a RESTful module
that offers several search
and detection services.
The project started
at the very beginning
for overcoming some limitation
in using the public
VIAF Web API.
We started the project using
the API available in VIAF but,
of course, VIAF, being
a public project,
doesn't allow a massive
invocation of its API,
while we need to manage more
than 100 million of record
for this type of project.
So, we discovered, we found
that this type of views
of Web API was not
feasible, and so we tried
to find a different way.
So, we tried to use
them for VIAF
and to implement a local power,
the search engine,
to use this source.
And of course, this was
just the first model,
but in the time we acted,
a lot of different sources
is in the same tool.
So, how to file our first
list of different services,
the class search services, for
example, the Authify classes
of services provides a full text
search service among the names
and works clusters.
The search Web API
uses, behind the scenes,
an "invisible queries" approach
in order to or to try to,
of course, find a match, as
much precise as possible,
within the managed clusters.
The invisible queries
approach allows
to make everything
transparent to the caller.
So, on top of a single
search request,
the system executes a chain
of different search strategies
with different priority,
and the first match
that produces a result
will populate the response
that will be returned.
For debugging purposes,
the response will also
include the matching strategies
that produced the results,
so the technician can check
and can use and can
improve the search method.
The system has been built
with extensibility in mind
as to manage different
sources and different format
and adding new services.
So, dimension of the chain
is fully configurable
by the project manager.
For instance, here is
a brief description
of the current configuration
when searching name cluster.
For example, we can search
in subfield matching,
so we can define
what kind of subfield
of each tag we can
use in searching.
Or we can input heading exact
match before the first searching
is okay.
If we try to find something that
exactly match with my heading,
or we pass it to a
full text search.
If exact match is not possible,
then the regular full text
search is executed with things
like a proximity search for
names and for other entities.
As last chance, the system
executes a search by "initials"
in order to find a valid
match in those cases
when the input string,
or the indexed heading,
contains the name
in its short forms,
and that mean you use usually
the initials to identify person.
And so in this case,
we try to find
and to identify the person
also using the initial of name.
And so, this is a type of a
response where the system finds
that Meyer, Bertrand is
exactly the same entity
that Bertrand Meyer, or Meyer,
Bertrand with or without dates.
But another service is
important in Authify is the
"relator term detection."
Starting from a MARC record,
the system produces an analysis
of tags that contain a
name and, for each of them,
tries to figure out, using the
statement of responsibility
of the input record, but using
in addition, for example,
field for notes such as
the content notes and some,
and what is the corresponding
rule
within the work represented
by the given record?
So, for instance, on top
of the following input,
you can see here a
declaration of responsibility
with two authors, two creators,
and Prefazione all'edizione
italiana di G. Biorci
and the three headings
reported in this record.
So, in this case, the relator
term detection was able
to identify two authors
for the same work,
and someone as having
an additional role
and not as co-authors.
And in this case,
we used the author,
that is an unclassified
role, when we are not able
to perfectly identify the role.
What kind of role?
But declaring of,
okay, not the role,
not the co-author is the
first step to identify.
And this is another example of
detection, entity detection,
with analyzing this statement
From Chaucer to the present,
John Stephens and
Ruth Waterhouse,
and having this field without
a subfield e or a subfield 4,
and in this case, the Authify
detect response, identify either
as an author and as some,
okay, as an author, yes.
And this is another example,
edited and introduced by,
and in this case,
this is the response,
and in this case the
tool identified perfectly
that Lena Jayyusi is
an editor in this case.
Of course, we usually can
find also critical case.
See, in this case,
Cedizioine anastatica,
introduzione e appendice a cura
di; con la collaborizione di.
So, very and many roles, many
roles for the same person.
So, in this case, we prefer
now to define, okay, other.
So, this makes possible
to a person
to check the record
using this response
and to correct or to input.
Of course, we are trying to
improve the knowledge base
with all expressions present
in responsibility coming
from different languages.
So, to have a more and more
increased knowledge base and,
of course, we need to do
some step again to arrive
to something of perfect
or perfectly working.
So, I show you a brief
name cluster process,
simply name cluster process.
In this case, we have a form
coming from authority record
from Jose de Lucio and
different forms coming
from different bibliographic
record, and the similarity score
in Authify, Identify, this
variant form as the form related
to the same person,
assigns also a weight,
a weight that is important
in issuing a term to accept
or not accept the class.
So, in the massive
cluster processes,
we try to give you
the main processes,
the things the authority
headings, analysis and process
in Postgres, the first step.
The data enrichment
with external sources
are very important
that we can use international
project already available
to identify the entity.
The MARC bibliographic process;
the entity detection process,
the name heading-to-Authority
name association,
but because it's not so
used; also, general use,
use the Authority authors
from all similar
bibliographic records.
Not all libraries have
an Authority system,
and the name heading to vary
and the name association
and the clusters check, it
exists and it doesn't exist,
it creates a new cluster.
But we have also
a manual process,
and we try to follow
the PCC directives
because PCC identifies and
addresses policy issues
on the use of identifiers in
MARC, and many items are now
in discussion into
the PCC growth.
For example, developing
guidelines
to include identifiers
in MARC bibliographic
and authority records; the
use of multiple identifiers
for the same entity; how to
use a multiple identifier;
determining the entities
for which identifiers
should be provided
in an initial implementation;
and identifying automated
methods for populating
and maintaining new and existing
records with identifiers.
But also in this case, the
importance of identification
and detection in the Semantic
Web to enrich a MARC record
with URIs, Casalini Libri uses
the "URI MANAGEMENT SYSTEM"
that is included into the
cataloging module of OLISuite;
that is the cataloging
module developed by @CULTt
and then used in Casalini.
This also simplifies the
reconciliation of varying forms
of the same entry
with the development
of detection procedures
for entity identification
and the conversion to BIBFRAME.
So, the URI MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM allows the management
of multiple identifiers for
each access point or heading;
the use of external sources
with API and web services,
or using in some cases the dump
of data; and associate heading
with the URIs that identify
it in each of the projects.
But this is just an example
of the URI Management System
in OLISuite where the cataloger
can choose for each heading,
define a URI System, and
it can add, check, modify,
or delete a URI coming from
different sources or can choose,
can search in different
sources and search
and check the preferred
URI for this heading.
But why multiple
identifiers associated
with the same heading
or access point?
First of all, because
Casalini produce records
for many libraries, and each
library is defined and preferred
in the form of URI, preferred
the source or a different order
in having different URI.
So, Casalini starting
from the same record has
to produce a different
record as final output
for different libraries.
So, in this case, we realize
the system that makes possible
to assign URI not in
original in the MARC record
but in a different table
with different system.
And so, for each library,
Casalini can choose how
many URIs to make available
for each heading; how to
associate them with the heading;
how to show them in relation to
data use and formats, following,
of course, the preferences
declared by each library.
And so the cataloging
system is related and linked
to the Adempiere system, and
that is an EFP that use Casalini
to manage all this preferences
and the profile,
customer profile.
The most important section
is the customer profile.
So, this is, for example,
the customer profile
for Harvard College
Library with a mapping URI,
and each library can
define the mapping
for each time they
can define, okay,
what is the preferred
URI if it exists?
In this case, for example,
uno1, sorry, 1 is for Italian.
Okay. One is for
ISNI, 2 is for VIAF,
3 is for Library of
Congress and NAF.
So, if he's in ISNI,
please put the ISNI URI.
If it doesn't fix ISNI,
please put VIAF, and so on.
And each library can
define a different mapping,
so that we can produce and start
it from exactly the same record
in that local database
to different record
with different URI
for each library.
And of course, each library can
define how to receive this data.
For example, as enrichment
in tag 100, the choosing
of the subfield; or for example,
as enrichment in Authority file,
choose the perfect and the
correct type and so on.
But of course, when we work
with URI with identifier,
so we need to also think
about to manage them
because when we publish our
data, enriched with URI,
we are thinking that
other people,
other projects make
use of our data.
So, we need to provide something
that makes possible the use
of this data in the future.
And so, we thought
about a URI Registry.
That is the history of each URI
when something changes in it,
and the, for example, when
we reorganize the cluster
because we discover
something that is not covered;
for example, we put
together two person,
two people in the same cluster,
we discover that this
is not the same people,
are two different people.
So, we need to split the
cluster and assign a new URI
for the second person.
So, the URI just
reports on this changing.
For example, the resource added
to cluster but also modified
or removed from it;
the date of the update;
the particular operation
performed and status
of a new URI, for
example, is valid,
or it is not still
valid, or the URI Aliases.
This is, okay, use this URI
for this entity and so on.
So, finally, we can start
the conversion in RDF and,
in this case, in BIBFRAME.
I don't give you the details
of Lodify, but just to explain
that LODify is the
evolution of ALIADA,
coming from a European project
that is a conversion tool.
ALIADA is transparent.
It can manage as LODify
different ontologies,
but LODify was the evolution
that we produce to
manage BIBFRAME.
So, the importance of LODify
gives you just a particular
piece, the possibility to work
with atomic pieces,
atomic processors.
This makes possible to
work with a small part
of the overall task,
and this means
that you can change the font
for each specific piece,
a specific class of
property of an ontology
or to change and so on.
So, this makes the
tools very elastic
and very powerful
and easy to manage.
This is a conversion template
because LODify converts each
incoming record by means
of Conversion templates,
and each template associates
a MARC record belonging
to the incoming datasteam with a
set of rules associated with one
or more ontologies to
produce the final session.
And finally, the
trust and provenance
because when you
publish your data,
or when you put together data
coming from different sources,
we need to think
about the provenance
of your letter, the quality.
You need to assure the
quality of your data,
and you need guarantee the
accuracy of this information.
So, we use the concept of
provenance that is the origin,
the authorship of an
information to extend
and to give trust
about information.
So, creating a link
between information
and its source has become
essential for the purpose
of guaranteeing the authority
of the information itself.
If so the triple
become a quadruple
because we add the third mode of
source to the claim that, okay,
it's not something that
is a universal value,
but someone says that this
is blue, this is this color,
this is the name, and so on.
Now, we go in the SHARE-VDE
Phase 2 deliverables that,
as Michele told you, was
finalized and finished,
more or less, in the same
way of the last year.
We have totally something
else, but we are more ready,
and so we have four
different deliverables.
The deliverable 1 is the
datasets in BIBFRAME 2.0
of the entire catalog of each
institution with the triples
or "tuples" derived directly
from the MARC records,
delivered both as triples and
as quadruples with the addition
of the provenance and
with SHARE-VDE URIs.
This first deliverable
is strictly related
to Deliverable 2.
It is the knowledge base of
clusters accessible in RDF,
and we think it is the
other value of the project
because each library can receive
their own data but all related
to the same knowledge base
to demonstrate also the power
of sharing data and of
a cooperating project.
The Delivery 3 is more
autonomous, is independent
by the knowledge base,
is out of [inaudible]
and in the Deliverable
3, you will have the URIs
from external sources.
So, not the Shelby D URI but
the international definition
of URIs.
So, each library can
use Deliverable 3
to publish their own
data autonomously
with respect to other libraries.
And Deliverable 4 is
the MARC 21 records
for each institution
enriched with URIs.
So, this is a version
of this deliverable
to the most [inaudible]
that Deliverable 1
and 2 are strictly related
to, and Deliverable 3
and 4 are autonomous,
and each of,
each library can
use autonomously.
What we have now with
BIBFRAME, BIBFRAME is for us a,
we are a sort of
pioneer project.
So, each day we receive news,
new information upgrade; so,
it's not so easy to
follow the project.
But it's a very, very,
very interesting special
phase of our project.
Now, we are managing the
extension of the Library
of Congress to perfect
manage in MARC 21 tags,
and we underline the class
that we already managed
in our state-of-the-art, but
we will continue, of course,
each day to include
additional classes and so on.
So, this is an example,
Deliverable 1,
the RDF conversion,
and see here the use
of LC vocabulary extension.
So, to manage some
specific information,
this is the contents of the
record and the deliverable
to the knowledge base cluster.
I give you just an idea about
a clusterization process
of "forename" heading type.
See here an example, Bridget,
of Sweden, Saint, with a date.
And so, this is an example
of the algorithm to
identify a person.
So, the selection of
interesting subfield,
we start from the full
tags, and after we go back
to find each piece
of information.
The first step is the
normalization of string text
without diacritics,
accents, and so on.
So, this field becomes
this field because let all
in upper case and search string
into db variance form
and cross references.
So, the fields become
something like this,
and if the cluster found,
because we use this heading
to match the string;
if no cluster found,
the subfields will be analyzed
for comparing, for example,
subfield a with other
existing forms;
or comparing only the
numeric part of subfield d,
having the same subfield a; or
comparing subfield c for "saint"
or "santa" or other forms in
other languages and so on,
to arrive finally to
identify the entity.
And this produces the
knowledge base, and we use,
as I told you before,
Postgres as a bridge.
We don't publish
Postgres database.
We will publish the class
assembly base in RDF
but we use a lockout
at the base in Postgres
because in some cases, the
relational database is able
to do something that the DND
[inaudible] is not able to do.
So, this is the final result
of all forms that we found
in libraries for this
entity, and we reported these
in Postgres, and finally
the results we published
on this form in a
portal because the goal
for this project is having
a [inaudible] library
and using BIBFRAME and new
technology, but in helping,
of course, end user and
use this information
to improve the search engine
experience and the use of data.
So, this is another complement
to produce a deliverable
and is a table for external
sources, a sort of map
of all external sources
that we use
to improve the record
with the URIs.
And of course, each
library can select
and choose the preferred
sources.
And so, we arrive to
the enriched MARC 21.
This is the original record,
and we [inaudible]
enriched with the URI.
Of course, we have also in this
step, a lot of dubs [phonetic]
that we try to solve with the
availability of Sally McCallum
and this group who help us
in understanding what is hard
to understand, and
also for MARC 21.
For example, we have some labs
or if you use the subfield 0,
subfield 1, to reach the record,
what kind of source is the
best to use in what cases.
So, it's interesting
this project
because it gives
us the opportunity
to share our thoughts with very
expert people, skilled people,
and to improve our
knowledge about this.
So, I ask Michele to
introduce the last three slides
that is the possible
steps for the future.
>> Michele Casalini:
We started last summer
at ALA during a workshop
of SHARE-VDE
to discuss preliminary what
a production phase could be,
and it came immediately
out of it that
and the scene is
very heterogeneous
because the priorities are
also different from institution
to institution, and there are,
of course, different workflows
to cover the other aspects in
both directions in the sense
from traditional
records into linked data.
But then there are also, and
this will be more frequent
in the coming future
data created
with a BIBFRAME editor
originally that needs sometimes
to be later converted because
of the operational systems
in libraries still
need, and the need
for a foreseeable long period
of time and MARC record
to place orders to handle
a number of services.
So, we started to work on a
list of candidate use cases,
and we had a very important
meeting here on October 6th
at the Library of Congress.
We were very grateful that this
meeting could be hosted here,
and where we analyzed
mostly the original
and copy cataloging use cases.
We will have, our next
meeting will be in Denver.
And the next couple of
slides give some details
about the original
and copy cataloging.
Maybe we need also a new
name for copy cataloging
and definition in the future.
So, so far, the candidate
use cases
for a production phase foresee
on one side the publication
of the entire datasets
on a portal
that should be no longer
a prototype, of course.
With that and a batch or
automated data flows in order
to allow libraries
to send the daily
of the new data they
created in MARC
or with BIBFRAME
editor and, of course,
to receive back the data
reconciled, enriched,
and with their preferences.
At the same time, let's say,
considering this as the basis
for a production phase, there
are a number of further steps
and further use cases
that you see here listed
as candidate Phase 3b.
And before we move on with
some further details about two
of these use cases, I would
like to join Tiziana's words
that expressed deep
gratitude to Sally McCallum
and the colleagues of
the Standards office
because without many answers
that we received, I mean,
what we have done would not
have been really possible.
But let's go here in
some detail, Tiziana,
in explaining this and
the next slide, please.
>> Tiziana Posssemato:
This is, of course,
something that we are
studying with the group,
so I cannot answer in detail
because we need to
define details.
But the general idea is to make
the SHARE-VDE project something
more than a publication layer,
more than a publication portal.
But to make possible
that the richness
of the project can become a
richness for libraries in using,
for example, the
cluster knowledge base,
during the cataloging
process, and so on.
So, the first thing in use
cases, try to analyze the flow,
a possible flow to that have the
SHARE-VDE project in the center
and the possibility to use this
important powerful knowledge
base of data to copy cataloging
or to define the
carrier and holding.
Okay, yes, a copy of this book,
and I can report is using
the SHARE-VDE portal
and the SHARE-VDE process.
So, we are thinking to allow
the contribution by libraries
to have something that is
useful in the cataloging process
and a world that makes
use of this richness
and exactly the same but with
different flows, of course,
for the region of cataloging
because this makes possible
the use of different tools;
for example, the tools
that the library will call
on Congress propose for
creating or for editing data.
Also because we are trying
to think to a new environment
where libraries not only
will publish data in RDF
but will produce authority
data and original data in RDF.
So, a new environment that will
use all these tools that come
from our project but
also from other projects.
I have a whole Library
of Congress projects
to put together and
to give to libraries.
So, this new instrument
to produce
and to manage data in RDF.
Of course, in this case, we need
to think to another scenario
where the conversion will be
from RDF to MARC, for example,
because a lot of libraries
will continue to use MARC 25,
MARC 21 as a cataloging format,
as format to exchange data.
So, the attention to change
and now we are thinking
to imagine these
processes starting from RDF
and ending with MARC 21.
But I hope to have
someone, a few interested
in these use cases
and to contribute
in developing these use cases
that now we are starting to work
with all librarians that
are part of this project.
So, I jump to conclusion
because I think
that you already can imagine
the conclusion, how important is
to sharing and to reuse
information resources,
how it could be important not
only for librarians but also
for end users to have
an enriched information,
a linked information,
to have the possibility
to receive also information
from online dictionaries,
online encyclopedias,
that usually they use,
and to have a common
knowledge base,
a common shared information
with all the world.
So, thank you for attention,
and if you have questions,
we are available.
[ Audience Applause ]
>> Beacher Wiggins:
Well, you've heard a lot.
What questions do you have?
Aaron?
>> Would there be a way that
we could get data from somebody
who doesn't plan
on sharing with us?
I'll give an example.
I do Italian law.
Many of the authors
are magistrates.
I discovered that if put the
name, the word, Magistrato,
and then even Nato or Nata, I
almost always get the Ministry
of Justice appointment list
where the person was appointed
or promoted, which gives their
birth date and place of birth,
which is very useful, since it
seems many authors in the world
like to have the same
name as other authors.
But of course, the Ministry
of Justice is not producing
this list to help catalogers.
Or another example was
Italy, for example,
I also discovered
there's a union list
of Italian Law libraries that
has cataloging, full cataloging
for records that the
Casalini record that LC
or OCLC isn't just like a
core acquisitions record,
but they're beautiful
records by Law Libraries,
but there's not any way
to get the data other
than cutting and pasting.
Is there a way from all
of this we could get data
without people having
produced it for us?
>> Michele Casalini: Thank you
because this is absolutely a
very interesting domain, I mean,
that needs progressively to
be covered, I mean, and there,
I mean, I guess, and totally
Tiziana can help me in replying.
This can be done through
various, in various ways,
using a source, I mean,
various data sources.
I make an example that is
not completely, I mean,
overlapping with what you were
saying, but just to tell you,
I mean, that there
is the intention
to address these
kinds of topics.
In Italia, there is an
agency, a national agency
for the evaluation of the
research output [inaudible],
and they have, and we
were involved in it to set
up a working group to study the
possibility to make, let's say,
better use of the information
and to have a database
that can then be
shared with a community
in a more efficient way.
The other, and also some attempt
to make use of the database
of ORCID database in where a lot
of Italia researchers are
now obliged to be registered.
So, about to mention,
it is certainly, I mean,
we have to double check and put
it on our list that the Minister
of Justice, I mean, and
of course in the extent
that they can publish
and they're willing
to make available their data
that list data is then included
for having a more
precise identification.
>> Tiziana Possemato:
And probably interesting is
also the role of publishers
because publishers usually
are the first people
who met the author, and
usually they can have a lot
of information that the
librarian cannot have.
So, also in this case, and in
Italy, there is an initiative
to involve the organization
of all publishers and be more,
more strongly including
this type of project
because they are really the
corporate body and the entity
that can have some
information to identify it
to disambiguate the
person or type of people.
>> A question.
>> Yes.
>> When will you release
the dataset and publish it
to the various libraries?
>> The participating libraries.
>> For Phase 2?
>> Yeah.
>> Tiziana Possemato: Okay, we
started to release in October,
and we are progressively
releasing to all libraries.
We left the Library of
Congress as last because it is,
of course, a bit
more complicated
and because we preferred to be
sure before, but we are working
in defining the last
requirements coming
from extensions, and we started
sending very, very small files
to the group, the BIBFRAME
group, so to check the quality.
And so, we think that within one
month we will end this process.
But of course, this
is important.
The Phase 2, the release of
this deliverable, is something
that progressively will continue
because we discover each
day new requirements coming
from BIBFRAME but also
from PCC, URI group.
For example, we are waiting
to have the final requirement
to manage work in subfield 7 and
8 because we know that some is
under discussion, and we are
taking part in this discussion.
But when finally a
decision will be taken,
we need build again the MARC
21 with the new requirements
and give to libraries.
So, I think that the
library understands
that it is a delicate
phase of transition
and that each day
happens something
so that we can improve
the process.
>> Beacher Wiggins: Needless
to say, I am encouraged
that BIBFRAME is a workable
and viable model based
on what you have shared.
I guess one of the questions
that comes out is you're working
with a discrete group
of libraries,
so how do you perceive this
being shared more broadly to --
is it all going to rely on each
of the individual member
libraries receiving its data
and then sharing that data
through a publishing mechanism
and making it available
for searching as opposed
to a single source that is
someplace that's getting
interested, the library or
cultural institution can link
into as part of a
linked data environment?
Obviously, I want to
share but also realize
that you are an entity
that has to worry
about all that input into it.
What do you say about that,
and I know you will be meeting
with colleagues in
Denver on Friday,
which I won't be attending;
probably the first
time in 25 years.
But what are your
thoughts on that?
>> Michele Casalini: Thank
you for asking the question
because it's, of course,
a very crucial one.
First of all, the
data is all your data.
So, you can use it to enter
locally; you can use it
in a shared repository.
I mean, it's totally up to you.
As the future of this
initiative that is ready now
in the very short future to
come out under the research
and development phase and
to go into production,
but what this production
environment will be it really is
up to you in the sense that
we intentionally don't have a
product to propose.
I mean, it must, otherwise,
it would not make sense.
So, from our perspective,
it must be really designed
and based on your
expectation to your priorities.
Another aspect to
say is to mention is
that everything is
totally independent
from the library local system.
So, what our feeling so far
is that, and this was one
of the goals, of course, of
Phase 1 and 2 of SHARE-VDE is
to improve that certain number
of tools are what started
to be mature to be
put into production,
and this then can
be used in ways
that really your community
will shape environment together
and to do certain things.
A consensus of a certain number
of institutions is needed
because otherwise it
can make little sense,
and there are therefore aspects
related to the availability
of the [inaudible] in RDF
of the knowledge base.
In order to have a unique
identifier among the community,
there are aspects related to the
production or conversion of data
after all the reconciliation
processes and enrichment
into linked open data.
And yeah, so let's
say it's really,
we hope now that there are
enough ingredients on the table
to play and to allow you to,
I mean, to express your vision
of what meets best your needs,
and this is the intention
of the coming meeting on
Friday and, of course,
the discussion will continue.
From the side of Casalini Libri
and our original
Cataloging Department,
we are now almost ready to start
applying MARC record enriched
with URIs or to supply
to libraries the
equivalent BIBFRAME datasets.
And this is, of course, as
original cataloging agency,
one of our responsibilities,
as we cover, I mean,
your cataloging for the
Romance language countries.
So, I'm sorry, Beacher,
if my answer was not
a complete answer.
>> Beacher Wiggins: Your
answer is about as good
as I would expect you to give
us on the spot, but I wanted
to hear you thinking
like that and to see
if there was any
reaction to that.
Other comments or
questions, Melanie?
>> Actually, I had a question
that he bounced off of me last
because one of the benefits
of the system we have now is
that we can't benefit
from others cataloging.
This is an example we put
in an authority record.
I made the authority record
as a baseline of information,
but the next cataloger works
with that person's name
for which more information
that can be added to it
and everybody benefits
from that.
I was wondering where does your
work take place in the system
since it is quite complex?
Is there any way that
it's, are other catalogers
or institutions might work with
the data that you've supplied,
that any changes they might make
to feed back into your system?
Would it be reasonable
to do it in the same way?
And not just as a catalog
results or perhaps, other users,
patrons who might be
able to say I'm looking
at this book as I'm reading it.
Oh, I could actually move that
catalog record to [inaudible].
So, [inaudible] that this
person was the writer of this?
[ Audience Laughter ]
>> Michele Casalini: That
and the feedback, I mean,
I answer certainly very
superficially, I mean,
so please, I beg your pardon.
The feedback of more
precise information
that is already available
or, of course, the addition
of certain data elements
that are added
with all the Provenance
Declaration, of course,
and are absolutely part of this
two-draft of data flow, I mean,
that foresee a cooperation
among the institutions.
So, there are institutions
that foresee certainly
to keep data locally but that
can take advantage of this,
I mean, Cloud datasets
and knowledge base.
There are other libraries
that foresee to rely more on,
let's say, on Cloud approach.
But in any case, this
aspect of interaction
of data is absolutely critical,
I mean, and very important.
>> Tiziana Possemato:
This is so important
that this was the first
request that we received
from our first project in Italy,
SHARE catalog that we built
with eight university libraries
and in the South of Italy.
And so, also, in this case, one
of use cases is the opportunity
to have a tool to share in the
first step of the production is
to share suggestions
for correction,
not to add it directly.
The heading without a
corrector authorization level
but to have a system
to share suggestions
so that also end users, and when
we think about the end users,
we don't think also to
students but also to professors,
to experts of the
mark up and so on,
can give that contribution
to the project.
So, can sciences can
send an information
about manifestation
and your work.
We handle two different
entities,
but this is the same person.
This is the same work.
This is the same subject in
different languages and so on.
So, it collaborative and
cooperative tools that will be
in different steps or grades
of authorization to arrive
to the last level that will
be the ability, if authorized,
to change the heading and
to correct, for example,
the cluster and so on.
This is already present
in our use cases.
>> As a clarification along
the same lines, so there,
from what others have just
expressed, there is an ability
for institution specific levels
of access for, let's say,
a specific vocabulary
like the Getty Thesaurus
or that won't be shared back
out into the larger community
will be imported and just used
in the same frameworks.
Is that correct,
just to confirm?
>> Yes. This is correct.
Yes.
>> Okay, I just wanted to
make sure I understood.
Thank you.
>> Beacher Wiggins:
Well, thank you.
It is 11:30, and again
thank you for sharing this.
I'm hoping by the time we wrap
up BIBFRAME pilot test 2 in June
and get our assessment
and you can get feedback
from external entities that are
using BIBFRAME we'll be ready
to say that the library
is moving forward
in this brave new world.
I was interested in pioneers.
So, again, on behalf of
the Library of Congress,
thank you so much for your time
and your effort this morning.
Tiziana Possemato: Thank you.
[ Audience Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at www.loc.gov.